are you looking to level up your Cloud
skills but not too sure where to start
well three years ago I had the exact
same problem I had just landed my
internship at AWS I was a complete
beginner to the cloud at the time I saw
that there were so many courses and
platforms to choose from and since then
the amount of resources has only grown
exponentially I still remember my very
first Cloud course it was Stefan
Merrick's AWS Cloud practitioner course
on YouTube and I used it to prepare for
my AWS Cloud practitioner certification
exam thankfully the course was exactly
what I needed and I was able to pass the
exam in three weeks after obtaining the
AWS Cloud practitioner certification I
ended up getting four more
certifications all with the help of
video courses and practice exams from
udemy I honestly could go on and on
about how much the courses have helped
me build my technical skills but in this
video I want to share with you the top 5
beginner friendly udemy courses I
recommend for learning AWS Cloud these
courses have been carefully selected not
only based on the user reviews but also
my personal experience of using them one
more thing before we get started udemy
is currently writing a special promotion
for their courses so make sure you take
a look at the links in the description
below to redeem a discount alright so if
I were to go back and learn AWS cloud
from scratch here are the three types of
courses I would invest in the first one
is the cloud computing fundamentals
course because when you're first
starting out it's important to
understand the basics of the cloud and
figure out if it's something you
actually want to commit to learning the
second type is an AWS certification exam
course these video courses will teach
you exactly what you need to know to
pass an AWS certification exam they
typically come with a bunch of lessons
as well as Hands-On labs for you to
practice using AWS services and the
third type of course is AWS practice
exams this will get you comfortable with
answering the types of questions that
may come up in the AWS certification
exam it will also give you a chance to
learn from any mistakes you make so that
you avoid them in the future now once
you complete those three types of
courses you will have the knowledge
needed to become AWS certified and build
your own cloud projects so starting off
with the first type of course I would
recommend this introduction to cloud
computing on AWS for beginners course
created by new day Davis this course is
rated 4.7 out of 5 Stars covers the
fundamental concepts of cloud computing
and is designed for absolute beginners
it's 7 hours long and by the end of the
course you'll gain an understanding of
fundamental Cloud Concepts like compute
networking and storage for example in
this AWS storage Services section you'll
learn how to work with EBS volumes
Amazon EFS as well as Amazon S3 but yeah
overall this course is great for people
who are complete beginners to AWS and
once again a solid foundational
understanding of AWS Cloud I've taken a
few of Nils courses before and he's an
excellent instructor who explains
technical Concepts in a very clear and
concise way I'll leave a link to the
course in the description below and if
you end up trying it out please let me
know how it goes by the way one piece of
advice I have for buy udemy courses is
to double check when the course was last
updated for example at the time of
recording the video this course was last
updated in May of 2023 which is quite
recent I've also come across some
courses though that have not been
updated since 2018 or 29 19. so those
ones are probably not going to teach you
the most up-to-date AWS services and
features another course I'd recommend
for learning AWS fundamentals is this
learn cloud computing with AWS in a
weekend course created by in 28 minutes
it's rated 4.7 stars on udemy and is
around 7 hours long making it the
perfect course for learning AWS in just
the weekend if we take a look at the
video chapters you can see that the
course starts off with an introduction
of the basic concepts and services of
AWS for example Amazon ec2 and then it
progresses into other topics like
security and devops for this course you
don't need to have any prior experience
or knowledge of the cloud because the
course will cover everything from the
fundamentals before you buy any udemy
course you can typically preview a few
of the course chapters so that's
something I would recommend doing
beforehand I also wanted to mention that
the instructor for this course also has
courses on Azure and gcp which I feel
like is quite rare because instructors
would normally stick to teaching One
Cloud so if you're looking to learn
multiple clouds and you want to stick to
one instructor in my be good to look
into his courses okay moving on to 80
bus certifications the best instructor
on udemy to help you get AWS certified
is Stefan Merrick Stefan has nearly 2
million students on the platform now and
his courses have honestly helped me so
much on my own Cloud Learning Journey
you can see that I've purchased six of
his courses and for each of them I had
left a five-star rating the reason I'm
such a big fan of Stefan's courses is
because of his teaching style he's able
to help complete beginners go from
having zero knowledge of AWS to passing
an AWS certification exam in just a
matter of weeks I also like how he
always keeps his courses up to date
which is quite important because AWS is
always making new changes and updates to
the exams I actually bought this course
back in August 2020 but what's cool
about udemy courses is that you get
lifetime access to the course which
includes all the updates so for example
this AWS certified Cloud practitioner
course over here is fully updated for
2023. one question I get asked all the
time is which AWS certifications should
I start with and in what order should I
do those certifications I shared this
AWS certification roadmap in a previous
video but this is the order I would
recommend so starting off with the AWS
Cloud practitioner exam and then
progressing to associate professional
and Specialty ones Some people prefer to
go straight to the solutions architect
associate certification which is okay as
well but the AWS Cloud practitioner
certification is definitely a lot easier
and more beginner friendly I'll leave
links to Stefan's udemy AWS
certification courses in the description
below and as always I'd love to hear
what you think of them another AWS
certification exam course I'd like to
recommend is this zero to Mastery AWS
certified Cloud practitioner course this
course is quite new but has already
gotten so much positive feedback in the
cloud Community I've tried it out myself
and Amber the instructor for the course
does a really good job at explaining
things that are very easy to understand
way what I noticed is that for the
concepts that beginners might find
challenging Amber simplifies it through
interesting analogies and Hands-On Labs
some of the course chapters include
Cloud fundamentals security and
compliance as well as being and pricing
similar to the other courses I've
mentioned this one is also highly rated
and comes with a lot of Hands-On
exercises but what makes this course
unique is that once you enroll you get
access to a Discord community of over
four hundred thousand zero to Mastery
students so if you're someone who
prefers learning alongside other people
this could be a great course for you
last but not least we have John bonzo's
AWS certification practice exams John
runs a company called tutorials dojo and
in my opinion he has the best practice
exams on udemy to help you get AWS
certified so I personally have used his
resources to prepare for my AWS
certification exams and I found them
very helpful in helping me identify any
gaps I had in my knowledge of AWS the
practice exams are very similar in
difficulty to the actual AWS exams and
the desire to simulate the format you'd
expect on the day of your exam each
question comes with very detailed
explanations and references to AWS
documentation which helps you understand
the reasoning behind each correct answer
okay so those are the top five udemy
courses I'd recommend for learning AWS
Cloud all the courses I mentioned are
linked in the description below and if
you found this video helpful please
consider subscribing to the channel for
more videos like this alright bye for
now